[Music]
so I think a lot about the role of
poetry what is poetry and I've come to
the conclusion that poetry is
essentially a technology of attention
it's a magnifying glass it unveils in
the full meaning of the term it strips
bare under a light and shatters our
indifference to the everyday it awakens
the ontological wow it makes us realize
that we are alive and italicized as
experience you know the paragraph of
subjectivity the narrator in our head
that's being written the paragraph in
real-time that is the voice in our head
that lets us know that we exist becomes
emboldened and underlined when we read a
poem the poem reads us it's a tool of
illumination
it's an alter something we surrender to
in hopes of
leading us towards the place of radical
exaltation
[Music]
Oh